on était sur l'article coup de gueule
alors c'était quoi ce coup de gueule le
coup de gueule c'est qu'il y a un
paparazzi qui les aurait non seulement
chercher dans leur hôtel privé si je ne
Londres à Londres et qui les a en plus
non seulement enfin ils a cherché ils
les a surtout suivi à l'extérieur ça
s'appelle après ils m'ont vu partir en
courant et du coup Monsieur Laurent
Ruquier a pris le soin de lui couper
l'arme sous le pied de poster une photo
sur Instagram en disant pas la peine de
poster la vidéo je m'en charge pour les
abonnés c'est un petit peu ça
effectivement terminé
et avant que notre ami répondent je vous
raconte un truc qui m'est arrivé moi
j'étais avec une célébrité sur une plage
me demandez pas qui je vous le dirai pas
et je voudrais et je ne ferai pas de
gaffe à vous de chercher
je suis sur la plage le téléphone de la
personnalité sonne c'est pas le mien
évidemment ces personnes je t'emmerde
pardon je relis je retire le téléphone
sonne voilà on est sur la plage on vous
a pris en photo il y en a des biens des
moins bien il y en a un qui a un peu de
bide on vous suit depuis une semaine
donc voilà ce que je vous propose soit
ces photos là elles sortent et vous
serez moche soit on refait une belle
série de photos de vous dans l'eau et
elle sera belle à vous de voir c'est
gentil quand même et mon ami qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit je ne transvise jamais avec
ennemi allez vous faire [ __ ] résultat
les photos étaient hachées les amis on
aura la réponse dans une seconde du
gomanoos et la Star Ac n'oubliez pas
tous les Sarran de les seuls à l'instant
j'étais sûr le coup de gueule de Laurent
Ruquier si vous venez de nous rejoindre
et bien alors ok a poussé un coup de
gueule contre les paparazzis pourquoi il
a dit weekend à Londres pour terminer au
cas où le paparazzi qui nous suivait
n'aurait pas eu la photo désirée autant
offrir une belle photo à ceux qui me
follow c'est ce qui s'est passé vous
étiez à Londres ouais exactement en fait
en sortant de l'hôtel le concierge nous
dit il y a un monsieur qui vous cherche
là-bas en tout cas il m'a montré des
photos de vous pour confirmer que vous
étiez bien dans l'hôtel d'ailleurs il y
avait une photo de d'un monsieur en slip
je dis ah c'était moi
parce que du coup ce qui fouille là-bas
ils nous connaissent pas avec pas la
télé en France et au moment et donc il
nous dit ça au moins on regarde la rue
et on voit un mec qui court en fait pour
se cacher dans un petit coin de rue donc
c'était le paparazzi qui attendait qu'on
aille vers notre lieu de de vous allez
manger au restaurant bref et donc on a
fait le tout le tour de l'hôtel on a
décidé de ne pas passer devant lui donc
il n'a pas pu avoir ses photos après le
reste du séjour on s'est un petit peu
caché on faisait attention de pas
croiser de personnes un peu louche et à
la fin du séjour Laurent a posté cette
photo je trouve ça plutôt amusant et
puis ça fait un pied de quoi
paradis ça les appareils photos comme ça
des télés l'objectif comme ça ils
peuvent pas c'est comme les flics d'en
parler cours après ils ont 800 kills 850
kg de débardeur de trucs pas tu as rien
demandé pourquoi je pouvais pas lui
courir après il y a aucun intérêt c'est
son métier le mec il a perdu il a perdu
mais moi j'ai pas de problème avec les
paparazzi ils peuvent faire leur métier
je trouve ça normal mais moi c'est une
question comment il savait que vous
étiez à Londres
ils savent tout ils ont des informations
des informations
ici et il avait par toutes les
compagnies aériennes qui sont des gens
qui payent et ils ont toutes les
semaines toutes les semaines la liste
des gens qui sont dedans et ils savent
qui arrivent et qui va où il y a même
des gens qui volent sous un faux non il
y a pire que ça pour l'avoir vécu encore
une fois on va dire que je parle de moi
mais je parle de mon expérience il y a
carrément même quand vous prenez un
bateau quand vous prenez un avion ils
ont les informations de qui a loué le
bateau ou le bateau va se déplacer moi
ça m'arrive à Saint-Tropez ça m'arrive à
Saint-Barth les les gens venaient nous
shooter
à la Barbade ça m'arrive à Argenteuil
des mecs ont suivi
ils ont les informations non seulement
quand vous voyagez en vol commercial
mais aussi quand vous prenez un vol
privé ou quand vous prenez un bateau ils
savent exactement vos déplacements où
vous allez être comme vous l'avez dit
très justement tout à l'heure ils ont le
droit de venir shooter
Vénus
j'aimerais réagir à ce qu'elle dit déjà
deux choses la première c'est que c'est
pas forcément les compagnies aériennes
en général 8 fois sur 10 les paparazzis
ou les agences qui qui contrôlent les
paparazzis ça vient des proches des
informations en général c'est ce que
faut savoir en général les proches sont
les premiers à donner les infos et la
deuxième chose c'est que le couple formé
par Hugo et Laurent c'est un couple
assez bankable parce qu'aujourd'hui les
budgets ne sont plus les mêmes qu'avant
et envoyer un photographe à Londres pour
prendre sa personnalité française et ça
coûte sur place et ça veut dire que
voilà il y a un vrai un réel intérêt
aller vous allez choper en photo de nous
d'ailleurs c'est justement pour ça que
cette photo là je vous donne une
dernière info vous allez voir parce que
moi j'ai besoin de Paris un peu un peu
Chico bon je le dis et j'ai un paparazzi
qui me dit mais j'ai comment tu sais où
sont les gens dans les restaurants c'est
Catherine Deneuve et tout ça on
t'appelle non on n'a pas moi ce que je
fais c'est que toutes les semaines
j'arrose donc toutes les semaines 52 € à
une frontière
dans un restaurant Chez machin chez truc
dans les restaurants un petit peu donc
toutes les semaines je sais que j'ai un
budget en cash toutes les semaines et
comme ça il m'appelle en permanence il
m'appelle au moment où ça se passe et ça
je savais pas ils arrosent des
concierges la plupart des concierges de
Paris dans les beaux quartiers on leur
pile billet de 50 toutes les semaines je
vais être consolider je peux vous dire
que voici le moment de sa création que
j'ai soutenu vraiment au démarrage qui
est quand même le Royal des mais oui oui
mais oui parce que les vedettes ne
prenaient pour des attachés de presse
pendant des années je faisais passer
pour bonne amie bonne amende bon père en
étant rien de tout ça et quand voici est
arrivé on s'est dit ah ça va leur
dresser le poil surtout il y a des lois
dans la presse française qui a pas
ailleurs donc il y avait des protections
et ben mais je peux vous dire que voici
il y avait un formateur absolument
partout dans la moindre y compris dans
la piste entière de la Madeleine
dernière info